هو سلطان الاجواء بامتياز اذ قضى 33 عاما
من حياته مسافرا بين دول العالم لكن كيف
بدات قصته بدات قصه مشاهدينا عام 1990
عرضت شركه يونايتد
الحياه على طائرتها مقابل
290 الف دولار وسرعان منطقتها ليحولها الى
الاستثمار الافضل على ما يبدو في حياته يا
سمر قطع ستوكر 23 مليون ميل عبر الاجواء
37 مليون كيلومتر وهي مسافه تعادل الذهاب
الى القمر اكثر من 96 مره حتى الان مشاهدي
لازار 100 دوله قضى مع زوجته 25 شهر عسل
في عام 2019 وحده سافر 373 رحله في 53 يوم
وهي رحلات تبلغ تكلفتها الحقيقيه
2.44 مليون دولار اي ان الرجل حصد اضعاف
ما دفعه في عام واحد بالفعل في احدى رحلات
ومشاهدينا امضى اثني عشر يوما متتاليا دون
ان ينام في سرير اذ بقي مسافرا ومستمتعا
بوقته فقط في الطائره وفي صلاه المطارات